white male Christian conservative this
is the stereotype of the Trump voter and
that is most of the faces you'll see in
a Republican crowd but Scott Pressler is
a little different
he is a young vocal Trump supporter from
Virginia and he is gay
to those confused by Pressler support
for Trump Pressler says we all need to
stop assuming we know someone simply
because of their identity we need to
start putting people into these boxes
and categorizing them based on their
gender or sexuality or or religion I
need to be able to look at someone and
say that's a person and I should talk to
them whether they're whatever their
color is at the Conservative Political
Action Conference this year Pressler was
a bit of a celebrity at tens of
thousands of followers on social media
he's also the co-founder of the
grassroots group gays for Trump although
the vast majority of LGBTQ Americans are
still Democrats Pressler said the number
of gay Republicans is growing
spurred by what he thinks is Trump's
unvarnished view of the world mr. Trump
he doesn't look at the world through
rose-colored glasses he looks and sees
it for as it is and you know when mr.
Trump talks about factories going
overseas when he talks about you know
our military struggling when he talks
about people having a difficult time to
even put food on their table that's
reality even though being gay in America
is strongly associated with being
left-wing there is a tradition of gay
men within the GOP they're called the
Log Cabin Republicans Pressler came out
to his conservative Catholic parents
after the Orlando nightclub attacks he
wants the world to understand that even
though he's gay Trump's priorities match
his he understands me he understands
that I want national security I want
jobs for our country I want to put the
American people for
he gets it and I think he talks in a way
that every person can understand he
talks in a way that he reaches us on a
more personal level than just campaign
rhetoric Pressler is pleased with how
Trump has governed so far keeping his
campaign promises and communicating
directly with Americans rather than
through the media even despite what some
might deem controversial behavior